[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مع واحد من اغنى اغنياء العالم ومتابعين
فاقع عددهم المئه
قرر حاكم ولايه فلوريدا روند مشاركه منصه
تويتر مع ايلون ماسك لاعلان ترشحه
لانتخابات الرئاسه الامريكيه
قرار راه البعض غير تقليدي ان لم يكن
غريبا ففي العاده الاهتمام الاعلامي
والجماهري يتركز على شخصيه المرشح الذي
يسوق نفسه للناخب وليس على شخصين يتقاسمان
المنصه
[تصفيق]
اعتقد ان ديسانتس يشعر ان هذا سيمكنه من
الوصول الى جمهور وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
الواسع فهو يريد تجاوز وسائل الاعلام
التقليديه مثل سي ان ان وغيرها من وسائل
الاعلام التي جعلها عدوا له ثانيا فهو يرى
ايلون ماسك شخصيه مؤثره بشكل متزايد بين
المفكرين المحافظين
يطرح نفسه كمرشح الجمهوريين التقليديين
فكحاكم لولايه فلوريدا وقع ديسانس على عدد
من القرارات التنفيذيه التي تحرم الاجهاض
بعد سته اسابيع وتعادي المهاجرين
والمثليين والانفاق الحكومي لذا فهو يحاول
استماله مؤيدي الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
كمرشح محافظ دون متاعب ترامب القانونيه
وشخصيته الجدليه المنفره احيانا للناخب
المستقل
سيكون قادرا على تسويق نفسه على انه
دونالد ترامب لكن بدون دراما لكن المشكله
تكمن في انه يريد ان يكون دونالد ترامب
كذلك لكن بدون القدره على تنشيط
المهرجانات الانتخابيه قاعده الحزب
الجمهوري ليست مع ديسانس حتى الان
وبالتالي فان المشكله التي نراها بالنسبه
له هي كيف يمكنه الحصول على الزخم
استطلاعات الراي التضع والترم في المقدمه
بفارقني 30 نقطه عن خصمه لكن هذا قد يتغير
مع بدايه انطلاق الحملات الانتخابيه ودعم
الممولين لذلك
اكثر من اي مرشح وبدا ينعته
التقليل من شانه
بعد الاعلان الرسميه سيبدا ديسانتس بعقد
مهرجانات انتخابيه في جميع الولايات خطابه
سيكون يمينيا محافظا لاستماله الاصوات
المتشدده في الحزب الجمهوري قبل ان يتوجه
الى مناخب المستقل في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
امام الرئيس بايدن هذا طبعا اذا استطاع ان
ينتصر على الرئيس السابق دونالدو العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات